500 kilos en métal pour ce dos d'âne un
peu spécial en 15 secondes le
ralentisseur se transforme en
dispositifs de sécurité anti voiture
bélier toute la foule est évacué on peut
imaginer ça à l'entrée d'un marché à
l'entrée du d'un événement sportif outre
ce mobilier temporaire peut être
installée longtemps à l'avance peut
rester en place entre différentes
manifestations et peut être activée ou
désactivée en quelques secondes
ça c'est la vrai différence par rapport
aux autres ils nécessitent aucune
surveillance
donc les forces de l'ordre peuvent être
appelés sur d'autres d'autres missions
de surveillance
sans être à côté du dispositif le design
se veut non anxiogène mais le logo
vigipirate ne trompe pas il s'agit bien
d'empêcher qu'une voiture fonce dans la
foule
ce mobilier de sécurité a un coût 5000
euros la pièce
le service de location proposé le montre
bien la lutte contre la menace
terroriste est un marché en pleine
expansion
malheureusement il ya un boom puisque la
menace est présente
nous ce qu'on veut c'est un menu une
réponse à cette menace là aujourd'hui il
ya une vraie demande des élus on a
travaillé très étroitement avec la ville
de saint claude
il ya une vraie demande vrai besoin pour
sécuriser les événements c'est ce
travail avec les techniciens de la ville
de saint claude qui a permis d'élaborer
un cahier des charges précis et de passé
les crash tests en avril dernier
jusqu'ici on avait des blocs béton qu'on
a commandé les dernières d'ailleurs on a
aussi on met des véhicules en travers
comme ça se fait un peu partout mais là
on a une simplicité d'utilisation qui
est extraordinaire et esthétique de
surpoids le dispositif sera testé pour
la première fois à la fête foraine de
saint-claude mercredi prochain